we're talking today about the changes in
the corporation and particularly about
the role that CEOs play in leading
American corporations we're fortunate to
have John Reed with us John is the
former chairman of citicorp and Citibank
and then after citicorp merged with
travelers he was the co-ceo of the
Citigroup then as an indication of the
level of respect the business community
as for him he was asked to serve as
chairman of the New York Stock Exchange
from 2003 to 2005 so John thank you for
joining us maybe we could start just by
getting your perspective on what is the
role of the corporation in the American
economy and particularly the
responsibilities of the CEO the role of
the corporation in the US has changed
quite a bit and I've witnessed some of
this change my own personal view is
businesses responsibility is to create
customers satisfy the customer needs and
do so in a way that produces decent
financial results on a sort of
intermediate to longer period of time
and obviously there is a social role for
the institution itself you typically
employ a lot of people you invest in
factories or in office buildings or what
have you and so you become a part of the
community and it's changed today this
idea shareholder value tends to define
the role of the company and economic
terms why do you think the rule the
corporation has changed over the years I
first became CEO and 84 at that time
companies were pretty well run by the
management the CEO was obviously the key
decision-maker but management was really
the controlling group if you will I
would say bye maybe 15 years later the
investors had taken control and they
have a very different set of objectives
and I think what happened is first of
all I think there was an extended period
of time
when stock market didn't give very good
returns there was pressure from
investors to get better performance
somebody got the idea that hey maybe we
could scare companies into doing better
it started out with something called
greenmail where somebody would take a
position in a company maybe they don't
five six seven percent of the company
then they go to the management and
they'd say look guys you really have
some divisions that aren't performing
you guys aren't on top of your game and
we want better performance from you and
if you don't we're going to lead some
kind of shareholder revolt well this
this took hold and management's that
tried to ignore this got into trouble
often were thrown out boards were
changed and pretty soon the shareholders
were in charge and what they said was
look management we don't care what you
pay yourself we don't care how many jets
you have flying around but we want the
value of the stock to go up in a very
nice way in a very predictable way and
we want it next quarter and by the way
it would be nice if you would tell us
and then to space on what it is you
might be earning next year and exporter
so it's on something I never did we
never in city during the time I was
there provided forecasts as to what
we're going to earn the next quarter or
the next year because they became
targets which if you were one penny off
you know the price of stock would change
and buy buy buy certainly we understand
the focus is more on shareholders and so
on but thinking about the role of the
corporation and the broader economy and
society what do you think are some of
the second and third-order consequences
of this channel I I think the biggest
consequences you're getting very short
term you know it's it's very difficult
to spend a lot of money training people
if you're worried about next quarter you
train people because you're worrying
about how they're going to perform over
an extended period of time makes that
investment well worthwhile but it's very
easy to cut if you're just trying to hit
a number and the other thing is where
before May
maybe you kept a plant open that maybe
could be moved but you'd been in that
community for a long period of time you
had a lot of workers who were loyal to
you and you were loyal to them those
decisions changed so all of a sudden you
said you know what we can't afford to
keep this plant even though it's not
really bad it's just not as good as it
might be so its eroded the relationships
both with community and with employees
suppose we wanted to get a rebalancing
of the corporation where it begins to
address some of these broader concerns
as well as the concerns of shareholders
any thoughts on a path forward I think
this is a question of values a CEO can
say look guys I'm not going to maximize
returns over the next two or three
quarters but i am going to maximize them
over a period of time and just you know
begin to adjust expectations I think
shareholder value has a place but it is
a factor amongst two or three and I
think the most important thing is to
expand this time frame a little bit
don't say hey I'm not interested in how
the stocks going to perform but let's
say I'm more interested now it's going
to perform over the next 18 months but
the CEO is going to have to give voice
to that because if the CEO doesn't
change his or her conversation it's
going to be very hard for lower-level
people within a company to start taking
a somewhat broader and longer look at
things we are in the business here at
MIT of educating the next generation of
corporate leaders and CEOs what role do
you think institutions like ours should
play in this whole process you have to
get the conversation going in other
words if people come in and simply say
hey the only thing that counts is
shareholder value and they don't think
about it they don't talk about it and
they don't say well what are the
implications of that well then it's sort
of like going to school and saying the
only thing that counts is great you know
I'm just going to get my grades I think
business schools here at MIT or other
as the schools need to have the
conversation that says hey there
shareholder value this is what it means
is what it brings now what are some of
the other values that need to be thought
about and what is the juxtaposition
because if you get the conversation
going then each manager as he or she
goes out into the world will begin to
have a more nuanced understanding of
what it is they're trying to accomplish
and they'll begin to bring some balance
well this is great John I really
appreciate it thank you